calorimetry refers to the measurement of
heat flow and in this worked example
we're going to
burn a marshmallow and find the energy
content of the marshmallow
first let's look at this setup for our
soda can calorimeter
so our soda can has some water in it so
here's the water in our soda can
and then we also have a thermometer in
the soda can
to measure the change in the temperature
of the water
if you take a stir rod and you put the
stir rod through the tab
on the soda can you can attach the soda
can to a stand
next we can put our marshmallow on a pin
that's attached to a piece of cork
before we start the experiment we need
to take the mass of the marshmallow with
the cork and the pin so we'll call that
we'll call that the initial mass and we
also need the initial
temperature of the water so we'll call
that t
sub i next we light the marshmallow on
fire
as the marshmallow burns heat is given
off and that heat is transferred
to the water in the soda can therefore
the water in the soda can
will increase in temperature which we
can see on the thermometer
after the marshmallow burns for a little
while we can stop the burning process
and once we stop that we want to look at
the thermometer for the maximum
temperature
reached and when we find that maximum
temperature we can go ahead and record
it so we have a final temperature
and once the marshmallow with the cork
and the pin cools down we can find a
final mass
let's say the initial mass of our
marshmallow pin
cork was 6.08 grams and the final mass
was 6.00 grams the initial temperature
of the water in the soda can was 25.0
degrees celsius and the final
temperature
was 30.0 degrees celsius
also let's say that we started with 50
50.0
grams of water in the soda can
let's calculate the heat gained by the
water
to do that we can use the q is equal to
mc delta t
equation where q is equal to the heat
transferred m is the mass of the water
which is 50.0 grams
c is the specific heat of water which is
4.1
joules per gram degree celsius
and delta t is the change in temperature
which would be the final temperature
minus the initial temperature
of the water which is 30.0 30 30.0
minus 25.0
which is equal to 5.0
degrees celsius
grams cancels out degrees celsius
cancels out and we find that q
is equal to positive 1.0
times 10 to the third joules that's to
two
significant figures the positive sign
a positive sign here means that heat was
gained
by the water which is why we saw an
increase in the temperature
if we assume a perfect transfer of heat
so all the heat that was given off by
the burning of the marshmallow was
transferred to the water
if we think about q for the burning of
the marshmallow it should be equal in
magnitude
so we can write q is equal to this time
we're going to write a negative since
heat was given off by the burning of the
marshmallow
1.0 times 10 to the third
joules so assuming a perfect transfer of
heat the magnitude of these two numbers
is equal however there's no way that all
of the heat was transferred from the
combustion
of the marshmallow to the soda can with
our simple setup
so definitely not all of it was
transferred for example some of it could
have been lost simply to the environment
and since the soda can is open to the
atmospheric pressure of
the environment so i'll go ahead and
write atmospheric pressure in here
this soda can calorimeter is an example
of constant
pressure calorimetry and since this is
the heat that's transferred under
constant pressure i can go ahead and
write qp
here in it to indicate the heat
transferred under constant pressure
that's the definition of the change in
enthalpy delta
h
so burning the marshmallow gave off
energy
which is an exothermic reaction
therefore the sign for delta h
is negative finally let's relate
this soda can calorimetry experiment
to calories in everyday life and so
let's find the energy
content of the marshmallow in calories
per gram
a food calorie has a capital c
and in chemistry there's also a unit of
energy with
calorie with a lowercase c so one food
calorie with a capital c
is equal to one kilocalorie or 1000
calories
with a lowercase c when we burned the
marshmallow we started off with a mass
of 6.08 grams for the marshmallow pin
cork and the final mass was 6.00
grams which means we burned .08 grams of
marshmallows
when we burned the marshmallow we found
there was a transfer of 1.0
times 10 to the third joules of
energy so first let's convert that
into calories with a lowercase c
so if we multiply by the conversion
factor of
there's one calorie with a lowercase c
for every 4.184
joules joules will cancel out
and this gives us 239
calories with the lowercase c
next let's convert 239 calories into
food calories so first let's take 239
calories
and we can multiply by the conversion
factor of
there are 1000 calories with the lower
case c
for every one kilocalorie and
that's going to give us 0.239
kilocalories and going back up here to
our chart remember
one kilocalorie is equal to one food
calorie with a capital c
therefore we have 0.239
kilocalories or 0.23
calories with a capital c which is a
food calorie
to find the energy content of the
marshmallow in calories per gram we just
need to divide
our food calories by how many grams of
marshmallows we use which was .08
grams in our combustion so dividing by
0.08 grams
gives us approximately three calories
per gram of marshmallows and that's
useful because let's say
let's say we had one serving size of
marshmallows which is
about 30 grams so therefore if we know
the energy content is three calories per
gram
we can simply multiply our our four
marshmallows
approximately by three calories
per gram and grams would cancel out
and we would find that those four
marshmallows that we wanted to eat
are about 90 food calories